hey everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
today we will be discussing the
fundamental differences between the
leading business analytics tools
that is the excel and w before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies
if you are a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn now without further ado let's
begin with our session
so we have our one point agenda that is
the excel versus w
since we are discussing the fundamental
differences between the data
visualization tools
let us understand first what exactly
data visualization
is so data visualization can be defined
as an act of representing
the information and data in a graphical
format using visual elements like graphs
maps and charts so basically what you
will be doing is you will be collecting
the data
related to your business or any
organization
and represent the same data in the form
of visually appealing
graphs charts etc etc so that the
information
what you want to represent is in the
more readable form for the user
followed by data visualization let us
continue with
what exactly tableau is
so tableau is a data analytics and
visualization engine that simplifies the
effects of generating interactive data
analytics and visualizations
similarly let us quickly understand what
exactly is excel
so similar to w microsoft excel is a
software
used to store numbers and data in the
form of organized sheets
excel can perform mathematical
calculations and represent the data in
the form of charts
now that we have understood what exactly
data visualization is and a brief
introduction to tableau and excel
let us begin with the differences
between the two fundamental business
analytics tools
excel versus w
so the first difference is who prefers
to use w
and who prefers to use excel so
basically
excel is preferred by the professionals
who are proficient in
extract transform and load operations
other than etl
dba also prefers an excel sheet and some
real-time developers also prefer to use
excel sheets
and now getting into table u the
professionals who are experts in data
science and data analytics prefer to use
table u the next difference between the
two is the real time support
so when you're performing some
mathematical operations on either of
these tools that is excel and tableau
there are some fundamental requirements
that needs to be satisfied in case of
excel
excel needs external programs for
running real-time applications
whereas in tableau tablet provides all
the real-time interactions
without the need of any external
programs to perform the mathematical
operations or to create visualizations
now the next difference between the two
is the skills required
now when you come into excel you need
some basic programming skills and
scripting skills to use excel but in
case of w
you don't need any coding skills because
it already has
all the database queries run against all
the data that you have loaded onto
tableau in the background
without the necessity for you to quote
something new
now followed by this the next difference
between the two is functionality
so the basic functionality of excel is
to store and manipulate data according
to the user's requirements
but when it comes to tableau the
fundamental functionality of tableau is
only to visualize data
and represent the data in the form of
visually appealing charts
and graphs the next difference is
related to automation
automation is something which doesn't
require the human interaction with data
but now when we come into excel the data
refreshment or whatever
the changes you make to the data if you
want that changes to be implemented onto
your data
you need to manually refresh it but when
it comes to w
w will automatically take care of all
the data changes that you have
implemented
so the next difference between the two
is cost the microsoft excel is not
available as a single product
if you want to use microsoft excel then
you need to buy all the microsoft
products such as microsoft access
microsoft powerpoint etc etc as
all of these come as a single package
now when it comes to w
w is available in different versions the
open source version that is the tableau
public
the desktop version that is a tableau
desktop so relatively you have
five to six varieties in tableau and
everything has a different cost
and tableau public is completely open
source and free
so compared to table u xl happens to be
a little expensive and
w is a little less expensive compared to
excel now the next difference between
the both
business purpose so the major business
purpose for what excel is used
is to get quick on and off reports
whereas for w
the main purpose of tableau is to learn
the business patterns and extract data
insights to
take up business oriented decisions
followed by this we have our next
difference the data source integration
now this is where the tableau has the
sharper edge against
excel since excel has compatibility with
limited sources such as another excel
sheet or some database
it cannot compete with tableau head to
head whereas tableau has powerful
compatibility with almost
every available data source maybe a json
file may be an excel sheet
maybe a data source such as dbms rdbms
etc etc or
cloud anything even a website now
followed by this the next difference
between the both
so the next difference is the capacity
so excel is suitable for small scale
data such as an organization data
but whereas tableau it has a powerful
capacity it can support both
small scale and large scale and some
bigger data sources such as cloud
followed by capacity the next major
difference between excel and tableau is
the language support
the microsoft excel has limited
compatibility with programming languages
it can support only c-sharp and plus
plus
whereas tableau is compatible with a
wide range of programming languages like
c
plus plus c sharp python r etc etc
now these were the fundamental
differences between the excel and table
u
now let us move on to our next topic
where we will discuss the average
highest salary of
w experts so according to glassdoor the
average highest salary of a w expert is
nearly 10 lakh rupees per annum in india
now we shall also discuss the average
highest salary of excel experts in india
so according to glassdoor the average
highest salary of
excel experts in india is nearly 8 lakhs
per annum
now we shall discuss the career options
for table you
so the career options for tableau
experts are as follows
the tableau consultant w architect w
developer
data analyst and business analyst now
let us discuss
the career options for excel experts so
the career options for
excel experts are to become an
administrative executive
project manager data journalist
financial analyst and
business analyst so with this we have
come to an end of this session where we
have discussed what exactly data
visualization is
what tableau is what excel is and the
fundamental difference between the both
and followed by that we have also
discussed the average highest salary of
w experts and excel experts
and also the career opportunities for
both these professionals
i hope the video was informative and
interesting if you have any queries
regarding the topics discussed in this
particular tutorial
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below our 24 7
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here